[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we started off the conversation you guys
are talking about kids and I I'm just
wondering can you just talk to me a
little bit about uh fatherhood and I we
mentioned you know one one of your
daughters represented you uh you know
I'm interested in how that felt uh what
was it like to raise kids in that world
you said you know your son your son was
a member you know uh I mean it was very
complex uh it's a delicate Balancing Act
and uh I'll tell you uh
I am very open-minded
uh I like my children
as I like the women in my life to be
their own person you know
to Blossom and to follow their own path
I
my daughter I'll tell you an example
when the war was going on
with uh the Mongols
my first wife Cheryl my high school
sweetheart who Beverly was good friends
with as well
was getting on me she goes you know this
club thing is taking over your life you
spend no time with us I read about all
this stuff in the newspapers I hear
about it on the radio TV won't talk
about it
she goes who are we now you know
so I
wanted to show her who I was you know I
wanted to spend some time with him and
you know just just
the Hell's Angel lifestyle I so I go
down I always drove a real low key type
vehicle you know I still do to this day
but uh I actually don't have a vehicle
this day I when I left to Spain I didn't
drive in Spain for three years and I
kind of liked coming back
starting over but anyways I'm getting
off track
so I took the kids to Santa Monica took
them to the pier on the Carousel and you
know all that stuff
and on the way home
I was driving with the family and uh
some guy cut me off once
cut me off again
gave me the finger
you know I'm just biting my tongue
you're on you know you can imagine I'm
in my 20s I'm in the midst of this War
uh
I want to spend a nice quiet day with
the family and uh
give you some insight into my daughter
in my relationship with my daughter
uh
the guy cut me off slammed his brakes on
there was a car in front of him
and then he turned around he gave me the
finger you know that's it I can't take
it no more so I jumped out of the car he
rolled the window up and he's giving me
the fingers too that he made a an error
he forgot to lock the door
so I opened the door you know I pull him
out at a 45 degree angle give him a
couple of head slams and work him over
and you know I get back in the car and
you know now my wife Cheryl's like just
like looking at me fuming you know
Georgie he doesn't know what's going on
you know he's a little kid and there's
Mariah like this on there looking at me
through the I'm driving I'm looking at
the mirror she just like won't take her
eyes off me it's been like 20 15 20
minutes
and I'm looking at her and then she
finally breaks a little smile you know
and I was like I get it that you know so
she understands me you know and uh
you know it's interesting she graduated
from uh law school she was the youngest
graduate ever in uh past the California
bars he was 22. wow uh uh the feds
immediately ATF specifically were trying
to figure out a way they went to the uh
you know Bar Association and we're
trying to hold back our license they go
you can't give this girl a license her
dad is so-and-so and you know they said
to their benefit you know uh they said
well we're not going to punish her for
his sins you know she's her own person
and uh
she just
started in this career of criminal
defense she was going to be a doctor
initially she's a Puget University of
Puget Sound and she calls me up
this is after I got found guilty not
guilty in my murder trial in 1987.
she's getting ready to go to college
and she calls me up and she says Hey Dad
how would you feel about me coming home
like oh [ __ ] you're always welcome home
like what's going on I've been
are you having problems in school she
goes no she goes but I've been doing a
lot of thinking and she goes I think I
want to be a defense attorney
you know the I said the defense attorney
she goes yeah she goes I don't like what
they did to her family wow and she came
home and uh went to law school and uh
graduated like I said at 22 past the bar
uh you know she's worked with some of
the best lawyers uh around uh and we'll
go back on Taco now uh Taco had been in
prison about five years he was doing a
life racketeering he was doing life and
he was also doing 10 years for ordering
my murder
so he had the life sentence then he had
the 10-year racketeering sense and he
called my daughter
and he goes caught me excuse me he
called me and said you know you're uh
daughter's doing uh unbelievable things
I hear he goes you're still on the
street after a 59 count indictment and
uh he goes how would you feel about her
assisting my
wow attorney yeah and I I said who's
your attorney he told me Henry Gonzalez
I think out of Florida a very well-known
attorney
and I thought about it for a minute I
said you know what Taco why not and uh I
said but I got to ask you a question
before you get off the phone
he was okay and I said look I know you
got a racketeering
life sentence and I said I know you got
10 years
for that hit on me I go what are you
going to do first the tender the life
and just [ __ ] you I said good talking to
you okay but uh so you know I mean she's
really created a niche for herself
George Christie III
uh was a Hell's Angel it was my vice
president for a while
of
you know he got voted in on the same day
I got voted in our anniversaries were uh
together you know he was in the club
over a decade he left the club
because of how they treated me and when
I say he left the club he's not the only
one that left the club just could name
off about 15 guys rapid session at a
concession that decided uh if this is
how they're going to treat George after
35 years 40 years I don't want any part
of it
but he
great kid you know
he was interesting he had to
following his sister's footsteps his
sister was a straight A student just she
you know shy of a genius maybe a genius
uh and uh
why can't you be like your sister I get
that constantly got that sure and he had
a learning disability
and uh it uh it was tough on him
he uh
somehow had lung problems and uh
he was 39 he uh I talked to him on the
phone he had the flu
he thought what he had was pneumonia and
he went to sleep and never woke up his
lungs shut down in his sleep uh you know
I talk about him in my uh
stage play I had a dream about him after
he died and uh very
profound dream
and I
wrote it into the blade you know it's
part of the
Final Act
and
you know I miss him
you know it's interesting Beverly was
talking about
we've known each other since we were 12
and you know we've been friends or
families were friends I was best friends
with her husband of 56 years he just
died a few years ago
and our sons were were friends best
friends and her son died as well at 39.
so uh
you know we belong to a club that no
parent should have to belong to that's
right you don't want to bury your
children
I have a
a transgender child I've never talked
about it publicly so you get the scoop
here John and uh I
I'm an old school guy
I don't if I'm going to insult you
you're going to know it that's right but
I do sometimes I misgender her his
friends
and uh probably one of the most
incredible artists
at age 10.
I had to take the lights out of their
bathroom
because they were in there they would
get epiphanies to do these art projects
and the only way I could stop him was to
take the light out of the bathroom so he
couldn't turn the light on and work I'd
get up at three or four in the morning
I'd hear something and they would be in
the bathroom and they would did
claymation I have a claymation they did
probably age 10 or 11 of uh someone
being led to solitary confinement and
the doors shut
uh the uh
just the art that they draw is just
incredible in fact uh
they are so good
uh the producers for Outlaw Chronicles
uh used uh them in the graphic design
for the show they actually went uh they
they said to me we're going to get
somebody to do this and I said well I
think I have somebody for you and on
their own Merit they got the job and you
know flew back with me and uh
you know did a lot of the graphics and
network and how old how old is he just
gonna turn 30. turn 30 at this this year
we'll turn 30. and you know you know I
don't know I'm going to say this and
maybe I'll put my foot in my mouth
to this is to parents
a minute
this is the parents with a transgender
child
you know you think you're going through
problems imagine what that child's going
through and the biggest hurt for me
was
having to say goodbye to my daughter
and then reintroducing ourselves as my
son and I don't know if that sounds
corny one bit uh I and I hope I don't
offend anybody from that Community uh
you know I love Aubry
incredible person you know and uh
now we'll get to my youngest
Finn
the rocket scientist who takes after my
uncle
and you know he's autistic he didn't
speak till he was five he somehow
come out of it uh talk about a master
negotiator uh
he doesn't like to be around a lot of
people so he created a this uh
he went to Chaparral School up here and
petitioned them to uh
to give him a spot there and he
explained his situation you know he
doesn't like to be around a lot of
people the things come in very fast for
him with his autism
and uh
they said no we can't help you well next
day I got a phone call
they said just Mr Christie and I said
yeah this could you send your son Finn
over we want to talk to him so he went
back over there negotiated himself a
spot in that school
uh during the course of that
he built his first computer I think he
was 14 at the time and he built his
computer and then he
got interested in physics and problems
and he created this problem and he he
asked me to take a look at it and I'll
tell you John I had no idea what I mean
it's just I'll send you a picture of it
it's like this problem might as well
send me I won't know yeah yeah so they
thought
possibly he was making this stuff up
that it didn't have any uh
wasn't anything it's just numbers anyway
it was putting together they sent it to
uh somebody local up here and I got a
phone call from this
you know mathematician and he said who
taught him this
and I said taught him what and they go
who taught him how to do these
mathematics and I go he taught himself
on the computer he started researching
it he goes this guy's he's a
mathematician he gives where does this
stuff come from I said you have to ask
him I said I don't even know what he's
doing I would go come in the house and
there would be
problems on the mirrors on the windows
with Grace pan well he'd be doing all
these things on the grease board and I
went to one of his problems and I erased
one of the numbers and
like a kid I did a Dickie bird a little
Dicky bird is
he comes out and he said to me I'm in
the front room and he comes out and he
goes
did you do this
and I go guilty and he goes you need to
grow up now
and I said hey I'm going to tell you the
same thing I told your mom I ain't ever
growing there you go so you know those
are my kids in a nutshell I love them
all they're all unique and like I
mentioned earlier they're all from a
different decade yeah
they're just like
yeah you got kids man you're just like
little little humans man right that's
what they are
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my son Warrior Shake they've
got the active active protein but they
also have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones for 15 off I appreciate y'all
foreign
[Music]